Hey guys hows it going, it's Justine
and welcome back to another unboxing video
and I'm not sure what's in this box
I have some sort of an idea
but I never asked for this, I don't,
I have absolutely no idea whats actually inside of it
It said its from Zag though.
They make protective screens for phones and cases and all kinds of things
to basically protect your phone from destruction,
and clearly they must've gotten the memo that I have a problem.
*dog barking*
and a barking dog might be one.
So lets open it up!
*more dog barking*
Woah!
This looks like a super nice fancy box!
This looks like something too good to be in my hands.
That's for sure!
*thud*
What the heck?
*music*
I'm--I'm--I'm tearing up a little bit.
Cause this is the most incredible, box, that I've ever seen!
I'm gonna--I'm--I don't want to do this but I'm
gonna have to take this apart to see
how they did this, cause this is just
freaking amazing!
This is absolutely--ABSOLUTELY the
coolest thing ever!
This is not sponsored, by the way, I now have to disclose when
things aren't sponsored because
apparently, some news station was saying
that I was getting paid to do all these
unboxing videos and I was like well
that's funny because all of those things
that you said that I did that I didn't
write hashtag ad on, I didn't write that
because I purchased them MYSELF!
And anytime anybody sends me something,
I let you guys know, but my god is this so cool!
So it  looks like we have two different
cases and they are for the new Samsung Galaxy S8, and this is pretty crazy because I am getting one tomorrow.
So at the time of recording this video, I don't actually
have it yet, so I'm gonna cut from this video of the unboxing, to me trying this out on the S8.
So welcome back, the S8 unboxing is officially up and now it's time to try out these screens.
So it looks like these are for the S8 which is good,
but I do have the S8 plus, which is the one that I'm going to be using.
So it looks like my sister is going to get herself a nice little,
curved protective screen on her phone.
So these are like a curved glass
and there's two different versions.
So this one is case friendly so you can use this
with a case.
Oh!
And this one, you can use without a case.
I'm still surprised at the
size comparison of these two because
there's really--I mean, there is a difference
but it's still--it's a good size.
Both of them are a good size.
Let's check these out. So these are curved, to fit to those sexy curves.
*whispers* Wow, wow, wow!
Application tool kit.
Located underneath tray.
I'm usually really bad at putting these on
but it looks like this is a pretty
official thing.
So I'm not sure if she's gonna wanna use a case or not,
Oh wow!
I'm gonna put this one on, cause it looks more futuristic.
Getting the treatment today, buddy. Don't expect this all the time.
This is in, like, some super futuristic
like, vacuum packed seal.
Do I put it in this thing?
Peel the clear area...ok.
Guys, this is--I'm not good at this stuff.
putting these things on.
Mm mm.
Alright. That's lined up.
Started from the bottom, now we're here.
Looks like she's on.
Uh, I think I probably did it wrong.
Don't listen to my tutorial. Watch the real tutorial.
That's what I'm gonna say.
Do not use a squeegee around the edges of the device.
Okay. Good to know.
I definitely didn't do the best job ever,
there's still a little bit of bubbles right here,
but, as I press on them, they actually do seem to start
coming out, so.
I do have faith!
I have faith that this will work itself out.
And it's my sister's phone, so.
Sorry. *laughs*
I just can't believe this box.
This is so crazy!
They even give you a charger so that you can charge the box.
I'm so sorry, Zag,
I have to, I have to open this up and see
what is under here because,
I'm super curious.
This is the coolest thing, I've ever seen.
Aw, I'm so sad. Oh, wow! Okay, so this is all separate pieces.
I don't want to take it apart, but I have to.
Gotta know how you work.
Oh!
Ssh! Quiet!
Hopefully that's royalty free!
Wow, wow, wow!
We're inside, we're inside!
Here we go, it's got a battery here,
This makes me so sad. I'm so sorry to ruin this.
*laughs* Its--this is how it works.
So here's all the buttons, they're each connected to this
little circuit board here, and here's our
battery, and this is the LCD screen back here.
That's a little speaker right there.
So if it's down, it's closed, and I'm like,
"Woah! I'm open!"
I think I might've broken it.
I don't wanna destroy it any more.
Cover it back up, oh yeah, I put this over here.
There we go.
*laughing* It's just like new.
(Music crescendo)